hey everybody and welcome to a gangsta
wild ride with steo it doesn't get much
more GED up than Young Buck baby and if
you're thinking W this is weird Young
Buck and steo get ready to find out that
we've got a history a real one and man
is it a hoot Plus for a guy who's filed
for bankruptcy twice who's been just
dragged through the worst of
reputational harm who's been to prison
and just like all of this stuff for him
to sit down with me and be his candid as
as humble as honest like I mean dude
really really epic really really epic
and I really respect Young Buck also uh
man
I just I'm a fan like I'm a real fan of
his rap dude so uh this one gets very
very very gangster so let's get into
it ladies and Gentlemen people of the
Universe I bring to you young buck
welcome to
Cashville you did yes you did so uh I I
just moved to Tennessee oh yeah yeah oh
okay got myself uh so you live down the
street you not I mean it's pretty far
down the street I'm way up North like
closer to Kentucky oh okay though but
you a part of the Tennessee tribe now so
it's like you dig like you're here now
you're us yeah okay
so
2005 G Unit tour 50 was uh touring
behind uh his uh second album yeah uh
and M was it it what was the name of
that tour Up and Smoke tour the uh Up
and Smoke open and Smoke tour yeah yeah
okay so they're uh they're
filming a Tonyo music video in LA and I
just show up on the set I'll never
forget it yeah I show up on the set that
then then uh then then I go with hook
kid to to his hotel and like and and
hook kid's like okay okay the bus is
coming the gunit tour bus is coming and
I was just like all right I'm on it and
so I get on the bus and and we roll out
to Vegas yep yep when you came down
those stairs in the damn cart yeah that
was in Vegas that's right but on the on
the bus on the way to Vegas right the
the bus driver is like very very serious
there will be no cigarette smoking on
the bus I remember that too yeah and and
and so I'm like I I open up a window and
I'm like hanging out of the window
smoking a cigarette out the back of the
bus at the bus driver is losing his mind
he's so pissed and he's like I said no
no smoking on the bus and I said I was
halfway out the window and the bus
driver says you think I need a white boy
hanging out my window on a rap
tour and this was like during your worst
behavior years oh yeah I mean it bro
like those years right there bro was
like the crazy crazy steo like the man
listen bro hey man all I can say bro
those are some years of my life too
outside of your crazy years them was my
crazy years too you did yeah for real
man for sure so after and I'm all messed
up I'm all drunk and then after the
hanging out the window thing then I end
up uh before we get to Vegas I'm passed
out on the floor of the bus Y and I
heard some I heard a couple things about
while I was passed out yeah like you had
a big bottle of mustard you squeezing it
in mou sque it in your mouth
bro I was like yo this is the that
he would do to a let me get
my let me do this to him you feel me but
steo probably just drunk that
like it was nothing bro that's that's
what that's what they told me they said
that uh they said that you filled my
mouth with must mustard I'm sleeping and
and in my sleep I like go h and I like
throw the horns and swallow the must
swallow the mustard bro I was like oh
yeah this right here is
just too crazy bro like I can't I can't
come over with nothing I thought I was
getting my my moment and man you
just had the de like oh yeah that ain't
nothing
cool I needed
that yeah and then they they said they
they said after that they're like all
right we're just not even going to mess
with him yeah man yeah and then somebody
was like try to roll Rox on my WR like
someone was trying to like take my Rolex
I don't know man we had so many it's
good that you was able to keep it cuz
back then bro we had we had the Sharks
on the bus you know what I'm saying so I
think it was you who who prevented
somebody from steal believe that man I
was like man y'all better not y'all
better not you know touch him in any
kind of way cuz you was lit and you was
really lit you know what I'm saying and
then I think a lot of dudes was getting
upset just because the bus driver was
still making up such a uproar about you
know the wild that you was doing
and just wild and I was like man
listen bro everybody know steo know how
he is ain't gonna with
him excuse my language you dig but I'm
in it you know so you always just been a
genuine solid dude well thanks man now
now I got a question for you sure what
made you go up those
stairs in a in in in in a in a in a
grocery cart right it was bellhop cart
yeah
lug I just had that dude I had it in it
was an idea every time I looked at a a
bellhop cart cuz bam my buddy bam he had
the thing where you get in the shopping
cart and and I was and you said the bill
it was a bill cour yeah yeah there there
it is and uh and you know and so I was
just like man throw me downstairs in a
bellhop cart and I got 50 to do it and
that was like I mean it was one of the
coolest things that was so crazy I
was like yo bro you're going to
around and kill yourself bro yeah that
mean that you didn't really give a
about we did it three times in a row I
mean it I was right there every
time yeah at this time were you at the
were you on the celebrity death pool
like uh was that going on too I mean
like the celebrity death pool was a
thing and I was uh I cost a lot of
people a lot of money by not
dying but uh but dude and then it it was
it was something really um it me meant a
lot to me and it just a wonderful memory
at the show on the Up and Smoke tour in
Vegas you brought me out during the
smoke break sir yes sir they went crazy
and said you know like come on out and
like I'm just smoking blunts with the
gunit on stage in this Arena and like I
just I was so happy and at the time at
the time it was uh like a hardcore
felony to smoke weed in in Nevada they
had the most no
tolerance it was like uh and and
everybody on stage is blazing blazing
bro it was like once we started it was
like everybody in the crowd the whole
Arena started you look up it was just
like a cloud of smoke like you was just
in a in a in a damn bonfire or something
you know what I'm saying so it was one
of them moments
where every show that we used to do then
doing a smoke break if it was any kind
of different celebr ities that would
come see our show or whatever that was
my moment to kind of bring them out on
the stage you know what I mean and not
every celebrity would come out and smoke
like I brought LeBron out in Ohio and it
wasn't like he smoking you dig so in
Vegas for it to be a zero tolerance
State like at that time it was really
really really big and the whole time I
was thinking when we was getting off the
stage man they F to lock my ass up for
this you know what I'm saying but
it it it went by smooth we made history
you know I'm one to can say I've been on
the stage bro in front of thousands of
people with steo smoking a damn blunt
where we wasn't supposed to smoke at you
dig yeah yeah man man and as a fan man
like I just I loved it man yeah man I
got I got uh introduced to hook kid in
2004 about a year before that and like
man I I I get in the studio with Tim I'm
like who who are we beefing with you
know who are we beefing with and like
they're just throwing me names and I'm
just like oh yeah well that dude's a
this
that threatening people and insulting
people he was a real gun Soldier bro you
did for real like like like sto just
took our beef in like okay bro gunit
over here oh y'all got a problem with
him you d
was this during your rapping days it's
it spawned my rapping days oh yeah yeah
like I I know I didn't know anything
about it I was just in there and I was
just like they're like they're like yeah
we got a problem we had a lot of did you
ever hear any of his rap albums songs I
didn't I was about to say hey bro
bu I was really going to say yo bro you
think you got another hot 16 in yeah I
need to put you on this I think he's
trying to get back in the game yeah you
trying to slide back in the game let's
do it
Ste this album we going to name it the
Wild Ride yeah oh my God so so then um
after I get like I it started occurring
to me uh like a little while after after
that like man i' I have threatened and
insulted like got some scary people and
and I remember I met Dave Chappelle I
said yo I said yo Dave and I think uh I
think my life might actually be in
danger you know like I got I got with
the gunit and like and threatening all
these
people Dave Chappelle said no man you're
steo you got diplomatic immunity whether
I have diplomatic immunity is Up For
Debate but what is not up for debate is
the fact that nobody is immune from
developing terrible habits I know a lot
of you have terrible habits that you
want to break and let me tell you how to
do that it's called fume this is a
diffusive device which simply flavors
air meaning there is nothing whatsoever
unhealthy about it
and I love it I'm not even trying to
ditch a bad habit I just enjoy it I
really do and I always have it in my
pocket if you see me ask me if it's in
my pocket if it's not I'll shoot a shout
out video for you and your buddies and
honestly I've done it that for everybody
who's asked me even though it was in my
pocket because I love it and I love you
I want you to be a happy healthier
version of yourself by dropping the bad
habit replacing it with the good habit
so if it's time then let's do this you
go to
tri.com that's TR R yfu
m.com steo for 10% off your journey pack
and it's called The Journey pack because
this is your journey to a healthier
happier you plus if you do it now
they've got this buy one get one core
deal the core is the thing in the middle
which flavors the air my favorite flavor
is mint crisp and the good news is if I
want to buy one I get one free tri.com
sto and use the promo code steo to get
10% off your journey pack now let's get
back to it you do that great and it just
I think it's kind of true because like
there's no street cred yeah and beefing
with with me at don't yeah no not at all
it's just like like why would you
because obviously you know you've
entertained people in your wild and
crazy ass way so it was just like I
don't think a lot of individuals at that
time even though we may had real
problems with them we looked at as if yo
oh he's he he's a part he's a gun
Soldier we going to get him when we see
him type you know so it was just
one of those times where we just you
know at the time 50 had a lot going on
and stuff he had issues with uh uh job
Rule and you know back then it was
issues with a little Sumer everybody man
Fat Joe and a lot of the individuals
that he kind of you know have a cool
relationship with at a point in time
yeah now was there actually like person
reasons why all that beef with like Jaw
or Fat Joe is happening or is it really
just to like is it just to like okay I'm
I want beef just to get more notoriety
or like no no it was real life I
definitely know the issues that that
that we were going through at the time
none of it was made up
for yeah he had a lot of things that
that basically um a lot of issues that
before I even became a part of gunit was
already there far as like the job rule
situ ation and uh a few of them I had
already been there but a lot of those
issues was just uh you know one thing 50
us always say which is true is uh you
know the rap game is kind of like boxing
everybody's fighting to be number one so
if you if you if you you know said
something out of the way or did anything
that he kind of felt like was
disrespectful then you know you know we
we made it more disrespectful you know
you get disrespectful we get
disrespectful you know what I'm saying
but we took it to the kind of extreme
like where we didn't U we didn't look at
it it was like just for the rap we
looked at it it's like we live in this
you know so if we see you it's going to
go up you know we going we going to see
what what that you said is it for
real cuz we going we going to bring it
to you that way so that aura and that
time like I say the issues was so real
that you know when we were wearing them
bulletproof vesses and things like that
that coming out on the stage with all
these guys with all these bulletproof
vesses you know those bulletproof vesses
was real that it wasn't a show you know
what I'm saying it was it was
individuals that was really of course
wanting him dead I think and and and
anybody that came along with him and uh
we lost a few soldiers along the way
that was a part of gunit in regards to
things being so real you know what I'm
saying that they end up losing their
lives and things like that so it
definitely wasn't a definitely wasn't a
madeup situation is it wearing a
bulletproof V of felony too I mean you
know some places if you're Fon oh really
yeah I definitely couldn't put one on
right
now but yeah man it was just one of
those situations man where uh even if it
was we didn't care because our lives was
this St we'll rather we'll rather deal
with it at that time through through if
we had to to deal with it from a law
enforcement place and and and before we
just get out there and encounter a
situation where we wish we had the vest
on you know what I'm saying so um yeah
man it was it was one of those trials
where in in my lifetime where I say like
you know I come from I come from
Nashville casville I come from the
ghetto I come from nothing you know what
I'm saying and uh you know just having
issues with different individuals wasn't
never new to me you know what I'm saying
uh just at that level it was it was
different you know what I'm saying
because we was beefing with guys that
were you know financially well off and
all of that stuff they got the means to
the resources the resources and things
like that so you had to be careful you
know what I'm saying man and so so uh
they then I'm interested with this all
the mixtapes yep
like help me understand from a financial
perspective the difference between a
mixtape and an
album
well let me say this it's everybody's
method is different when it comes to
dropping say
mixtapes and actually financially
gaining from it you know you could drop
a mixtape and uh create a situation
where you have a contract that's in
place with distribution as well and see
and see you know financially just like
you would an album type of thing or a
lot of times a lot of guys uh I mean
mixtape wise you can hand toand these
things as well you understand what I'm
saying my career kind of was started
with gunit by basing it off of my own
personal mixtape but here it is I'm
selling back then we had CDs so you know
uh at the time it might have cost me
$300 to press up a th000 CDS I'm selling
them for $10 a piece you do the math so
so the financial is different now far as
from an album of course you got a budget
you understand uh some of it's
recoupable you dig what I'm saying and
some of it's not uh streaming and all
those things that we deal with now
wasn't really just big back then but I
do remember uh Jimmy iine having a
conversation with 50 years and years
before the game is at where it's at now
that it was going to become what we're
living so 50 kind of had a head start on
things bro like I mean he was one of the
dudes that was really really uh ahead of
a lot of other individuals in the game
because he was able to capitalize even
with gunit by you know taking us
overseas before it became like we were
one of the first real real uh think rap
groups that that really International
internationally toured and and and and
you know he he would keep us over there
as well and now you look around you see
a lot of lot of artists and stuff you
know traveling in the world but at those
times the music would drop in the United
States but by time we would go overseas
it would be brand new so it's was like
okay here it is we touring over here
then we'll go overseas and and and T A
but the music was just now coming out
now you put it out of hits the world
immediately you know with the streams
and the whole internet thing and you
know that's that's that's one of the
things but financially gaining it's just
different ways right that uh cuz some
some
individuals uh in the rap game they can
possibly make more off of mixtape than
they would an album now you don't know
the difference you know what I'm saying
with all of the streaming because a lot
of artists now are just paid out through
streaming right you know or or you know
a lot of hard copies is not it's not
really there of course you can get your
iTunes sales and things like that but a
lot of people are just streaming
streaming records and I don't think it's
really fair numbers that artists get
from stream from the streaming platforms
at all but did the Snoop Dog just came
out and said he had a billion streams
and he only made 45,000 exactly you
which is crazy which is crazy and I
think uh you know artists uh in all
genres of music should team together and
and and fight that you know what I'm
saying because it's our art you know and
uh I think we should be compensated way
more than uh like you said a billion
streams $45,000 it was it was a point in
time where you sell a million records
and you see a million dollars it was
that 4 cents a th000 downloads yeah it
just depends on the percentage that you
had involved in your situation but now
it's just a lot of artists are making
the money I think from uh touring of
course and merch and things like that
like welcome the cash you know what make
sure y'all click my link and grab you
some merch you know the cash get you did
but yeah that's that you're exactly
right bro when you guys are touring
around like throughout Europe do you
guys hire a professional blunt roller to
to go with you guys or you am the
professional BL you you dig but I did I
did have I did have my guy shout out to
Dwight you know what I'm saying but uh
yeah I kept I kept one of my guys with
me that you know what I'm saying that
would always keep it together but I
still feel like I'm the tightest you dig
do you pay him per blunt or just a
definitely not per blun cuz if that was
the case I would have been
broke but I made sure that he was well
taken care of though you know what I'm
saying it was like uh if I make money
they make money my circle was in in in
in a sense it was one of those good and
bad things because it got to a point
where I slowed down for making money and
then the circle started not making money
and Resort him back to doing crazy
and some of my circle is not here now
too you dig so yeah it it was like I say
man it was the biggest experience for me
because truthfully I had already
established myself as an as an as a
known artist before I became a part of
gunit you know and and it started out
with me uh uh just rocking through my
cash money days I I had a uh um when
still do got a real close friend that
kind of you know brought me around those
guys at a very young age so honestly I
thought my career would would would have
Happ through cash money and uh it it it
didn't and and end up you know meeting
50 and 50 gave me that opportunity to uh
to become what what I became to the
world and I'm I'm forever grateful for
that you know now cash money was with
baby and Lil Wayne baby and Lil Wayne
yep yep I came up with Lil Wayne a
juvenile Turk you know what I'm saying
baby baby was like always like a father
figure to us all and even now I still
look at him as the big dog you know what
I'm saying because uh he gave me a lot
of a lot of opportunity and a lot of
game since I was a Youngster just by
being amongst them and uh now were you
touring with cash money let me tell you
what happens when you're on tour you
cover a lot of ground and you put in a
lot of work and the best way to know how
much ground you covered and how much
work you put in is to wear a whoop band
the most sophisticated Fitness tracking
device known to man it tells me
everything about the calories I'm
burning how I'm burning them it like
when I ride a bicycle it knows the app
is unbelievable it tells me every stage
of sleep I was in how long I was in each
stage how many calories I burned how I
burned them how my heart is performing
what's my skin temperature like how
oxygenated is my blood I mean like there
is just no other Fitness tracking device
that's going to give you that kind of
information it's called whoop baby and
if you're not wearing it then you just
don't know what's going on with your
body and the way that I'm chopping wood
these days like I love looking at it I
love going to bed at night knowing that
I put in that work I love waking up
knowing that I got that rest and I want
you to know these things too so go to
whoop.com that's
wh.com and use the promo code steo for
10% off your membership it's big savings
and it's very very well worth it plus
you can put together fun groups with
your buddies and so everybody knows who
got the best recovery who burned the
most calories who got the most straining
I mean it's a lot of fun so one more
time go to whoop.com that's
wh.com and use the promo code stea for
10% off your membership now let's get
back to it
yeah I was torn bro I never got to a
point where I was able to release any
any music but I was a part of uh the
whole era of the beginning of of uh the
hot boys and stuff like that and U and
there was a point where after gunit you
kind of went back to the Cash Money
group right well at a point in time I um
no I never went back to Cash Money uh I
went to rocking with juvenile okay yeah
see juvenile had had a start his own uh
his own label which was UTP and I rocked
with him and was a part of that but I
never got to sign a contract even in
that situation we put out a project that
was uh that that that did pretty well
back then and uh you know from there um
you know he had we we kind of had a
situation where I was actually with
juvenile when I met 50 c you understand
what I'm saying and 50 was in in New
York we we had a a bus that we traveled
on with the studio and all of that stuff
when I was with Juvenile and juvenile
was a workaholic you know what I mean
and when we got up there rest in peace
but our bus driver that same bus driver
that you talking about he passed away
you know what I'm saying and uh he was
one of baby's real good friends too rest
in peace to CEO and um you know I was
actually with juvie when I met 50 we was
in New York a bus driver had connections
with an individual that that by the name
of sha money uh that that rock with 50
and 50 was big on the mixtape scene and
stuff like that he came by the bus they
were actually doing a record I was in
the front playing records for banks and
yo and uh that was The Blood Hound The
Blood Hound was the first record that
that actually introduced me to gun and
actually that was a record that I had
already for myself the world doesn't
know this so y'all getting exclusive on
the Wild Ride
yeah but yeah that that blood hound
record was actually my record right and
I was playing that record in the front
of the bus and I think it caught 50's
attention he was like but his Banks
heard it and then he brought it back
Banks brought took it back to 50 and he
was like yo and then 50 heard the record
and he really didn't give me a reaction
like he was going to take the record and
put it on his album he was kind of like
yeah that's that's it and uh after my
separation came with juvenile is when uh
shamoney reached out and was like yo bro
what you doing I'm like man I'm I'm just
here right now man he was like look 50
wants this record on his I'm like what
so I never had been you know officially
ever paid for a record like that and uh
he actually lined me up paid me good he
got the record and kept kept uh my
second verse and he put his two verses
on to the record and that's that that
started it you know once they seen I was
a free agent um offered me a contract
and hey man I took it and never look
back you know uh when when when when
somebody like 50 offers to buy your
album or or you know by that song are
you like yeah and in the back of
your head you're like okay dude how do I
protect myself or you just like get this
out there I was a little bit all of
the above well at the point you you had
never sold any music never
so I didn't really know how it work so I
even and see that's that a lot of things
that I've experienced you know even now
going through was based off of me just
not knowing and making those decisions
for myself and at those times I I didn't
have a lot of individuals around me that
were uh yeah actually in the game that
could even give me the knowledge so I
had to get out here and take the bumps
and bruises for myself from making
mistakes from signing this or not asking
about this and uh in the in the in the
long run it started to started to affect
me because of the the moves and
decisions that I made you know in the
beginning but I was excited from the
beginning of you
know he wants my record you know what
I'm saying and then it's like he's with
M and Dre and then what really done it
was when they was like yo m is crazy
about the record I'm like what M knows
me like what like m yeah he mixed the
record shamani was like yeah he's mixing
Eminem actually mixed Blood Hound so I
really was through the roof then and I'm
like you know Jesus Christ and u i
remember going to um juveniles manager
at the time and uh and uh his name is
Ron Ron bird and uh reaching out to him
like yo I need help bro I you know I
don't really know what to do so he acted
as a manager and I became he became my
manager juveniles manager uh at that
time he became you know who I Look to
actually help me with this contract and
everything like that but it didn't it
didn't go through with me being able to
keep Ron we we remain great friends even
now but it didn't go go through that way
being that uh you know 50 had like a
umbrella kind of set up already of of
the individuals uh within the company
and then it was more one of those things
where he was like uh you can come in up
under this umbrella we're not really
accepting mhm the outside type of thing
so you had to be with sha money yeah I
had to make sha money but basically sha
money was the manager of all of us at
that time like uh me banks yo for sure
you know what I'm saying he he never
managed game uh but yeah I came in on
umbrella they had the manager the
lawyers already there and everything in
place so it was like I had to have that
rough conversation with Ron like yo you
know I'm going to take this chance and
this wrist on my own and I didn't have a
blanket or nobody of knowledge of of
that I just went straight in up under up
under that um umbrella and um and then
the umbrella goes away You're supposed
to get out from under the umbrella and
that's where the problems came that's
when the problems came you know um like
I say man
me I've went through all those fa is
where I've I've I've went back and forth
with 50 and things like that about
things that I felt he done to me or or
or could have helped do do for me all of
those things I'm in a place now where I
don't have nothing negative to say about
a 50 Cent other than you know we had
some great times I appreciate the
opportunity that you gave me I'm forever
grateful for it and uh you know I'm my
Best Is Yet To Come you know what I'm
saying I I technically released two
albums solo wise but they're all they're
both you know you know over Platinum you
dig what I'm saying outline outside of
the work that I did actually with gunit
as a group all our records we sold
millions and millions of Records so I'm
just in a place now where it's so much
more to my Artistry than even just rap
you know I'm a I'm a I'm a writer I'm an
artist so I can actually create music
for anything and anybody so I found
myself now in different genres of music
and rocking with different artists I
mean I'm from Nashville so of course
I've got a few country Rec records and
stuff that's coming through and and
stuff like that and uh I'm real close
with yellow wolf and uh 36 mafia yeah we
got a project that's about to drop um
this year that's just you and DJ Paul
yeah DJ Paul produced the entire entire
record but we got few features big name
features on the record cool man and um
man just stand at it so your your two
albums are straight out of Cashville and
buck the world Buck the world yeah and
uh that was with gunit but my mixtape
catalog is pretty good good now when
you're working under 50 in gunit do you
have a lot of creative control or do you
really have to like run everything by 50
before you uh go ahead and Greenlight
everything I'm going to be honest I'm
such a workaholic that
he he he would give me me I would say
like a lot of creative control not only
for my own projects but for the actual
group too because um the gunit album beg
for mercy 50 was you know able to uh you
know show up for that record when he was
able to because you know he had get rich
a Dr Trine that was so big and then you
know here he is putting out a record
with us so the creative control was kind
of left left in between me and banks at
that time you know what I'm saying so uh
he would come in and we would have
certain records that we may have and 50
would just jump on those records or we
would uh you know get chances Where We
Vibe together and stuff like that or I
would just have records and be like yo I
got this what y'all think they'll jump
on the record and stuff like that so
creative control 50 pretty much would
let you you know have that control on on
what you what you choose to do with your
own project but his opinion he got the
last word over over everything though
you know whose idea was uh gunit South
that was me that was you yeah from this
very day you know uh it was a situation
where we were becoming so big and so
fast and I was the only Southern artist
within the group
you know what I'm saying so it was like
let me start to kind of bring more
Southern artists in my mind to the table
and create my own label so when I ran it
by him he he greenlighted it you know he
was like yo that's that's that's perfect
so I started the brand gunit South as
much as possible in hopes of being able
to go get a a distribution SE
situation uh of my own to be able to
bring more artist to the table not just
Southern artists but like kind of create
another branch of the label where where
we will be able to uh have more artists
to be able to be signed so gunit South
turned into
Cashville Cashville pretty much pretty
much gun South was like was everything
that I was focusing on and then once
once everything kind of started going
south uh from that I I I had to keep
keep it going so casville records which
is what I started to uh brand and and
bring to the table at that time and
that's where I'm at now you know the
difference between me and young buck is
that I only have one artist on my
label and it's important to me that I
keep her happy which is why I use blue
CH tablets baby honey how much do you
love it when I show you my blue tongue
oh
I genuinely get so excited I love it
yeah she screams with joy because she
knows it's going down and I think it's
going down
tonight yeah it is time to wrap it
up okay so before I get my blue CH going
on with with my lady Lux let me tell you
how you can get an entire month supply
of these phenomenal Bluetooth tablets
completely for free and if you don't
know what they're about they've got the
same active ingredient as both Viagra
and Calis except they're delicious
they're chewable and they're only a
fraction of the price so to get your
month's Supply you go to
bluechew.com and use the promo code steo
you consult with the medical provider
right there on the website take care of
your prescription and then boom an
entire month supply of blue Cho tablets
is on its way to you absolutely for free
all you pay is five bucks for shipping
and if you're wondering if it's going to
be a good time let me assure you I have
a really good time every time so one
more time go to bluechew.com and use the
promo code steo to get an entire month
supply of blueo tablets completely for
free all you pay is five bucks for
shipping now let's get back to
it you know I'm I'm in a I'm in a a
process of being a free agent so going
into into 2024 I'm basically going into
this this year as a free agent uh not
just so quick to just run and jump in
another deal with with with uh with
uh any old label any old label like that
I'm just you know I've I've been I've
been independently pushing for a while
now and I've I've been blessed to make a
few dollars and from independently
pushing and just trying to really really
regroup and Rebrand myself
because I've been through a lot of
different things in regards to uh just
trying to get out of my contract you
know I've been through the bankruptcy
situations and stuff like that and
people have never left my side based on
I think the talent that I bring to the
table for a while I wasn't able to kind
of drop no music because you know it got
to a point where I put something out and
50 was ceasing de ceas and deising my
music and stuff like that so all of
those things stop you know what I'm
saying and uh like I say man I'm I'm in
a place now where I'm able to do what I
want it's like a breath of fresh air
like finally you know what I'm saying
yeah it's like all the stuff with 50 and
you know declaring the bankruptcy like
the selling the music yeah that that
feels to me a little bit like Dre
leaving Death throw records I here just
Happ it I start over that's exactly what
I did you know honestly it got to a
point where it was like um you know
uh with me filing my
bankruptcy of course made guns contract
become a part of my my bankruptcy
because uh in the beginning he uh filed
a I think a
$250,000 claim but this was three years
ago and I knew it was a lot of bogus I
didn't know why he was making that claim
CL but he never was he never provided
anything in regards to the claim you
know with that kind of money you're
going to have some kind of track record
or Bank doc documentations or anything
so this was three years ago and uh he I
don't know why he made that claim but
what's so interesting is before I got
here that's why I was a little bit late
I'm actually in the process of just now
getting to the discharging of my
bankruptcy and they made a claim
probably like 5 hours ago for the same
$250,000 I'm like what are you serious
even the attorneys is
like this is about to be wrapped up you
know you had three years you passed over
two or three deadlines y'all haven't
said nothing so I think a lot of it is
just I don't know what I did to do to
make him actually want to see me not
feed my children and stuff like that I I
I don't I I never I never
had I just don't know what what 50 is
his own his own his own you know person
and stuff like that but I would I
wouldn't never wish de or want to not
see him be able to feed his family yeah
we had our misunderstandings I don't
even call them beeps and stuff like that
but yeah we had our misunderstanding but
to uh to do some of the things that he's
done and attempt to try to discredit my
name discredit me as a person to damage
my character out here and uh you know
put out all this false narratives of
different things in regards to certain
craziness that I've went through it's
just
like you rich my man you still doing
your thing I want I love your I love
your TV show Power you know what I mean
why are you doing this to me you know I
mean like bro we was once Brothers y'all
you know I've always looked at you as
big bro you know what I'm saying yes I
made mistakes too but I've never did
anything to try to take food out of your
your your mouth or stop you from eating
so it's just like see how aggressive he
is towards me makes me feel like damn is
you trying to JY me too you like is it
true that uh the the 50 stepped up and
paid your taxes like in my first this is
my second time having to go through this
but in the first time I dealt with it he
did uh he did help me I he didn't
actually 50 never paid nothing that I
didn't have to pay back so even though
he might have yeah he did help I still
had to give him that money back so what
he did do I didn't have and when I did
start to have he made sure he got his
back so so the but that's still helpful
that's still very helpful cuz if it
wasn't for him I wouldn't I wouldn't
have know what to do right you know like
I said I didn't have a lot of knowledge
of this so once I made a few
dollars my first time having to deal
with bankruptcy was like okay I mean I'm
I'm a full-fledged celebrity my mother
still lived down the street in the
projects she's got to a point where she
didn't want to leave but now you got the
whole neighborhood dropping music off on
the porch and stuff like that I'm all
over TV so once I made a few dollars bro
my living circumstances was so crazy and
of course I might have added on a little
bit more extra but the first thing I did
was you know bought my mom's a
house bought myself a house and and and
and I bought everything I was supposed
to and I shouldn't bought you dig yeah
so here it is come the end of the year
I'm def near broke and relying on other
money coming in that to to get me back
together and then all of a sudden they
hit me with this text thing that was
like what is this right so I didn't have
I didn't have have knowledge of even
what it's the first time I ever filed
texes in my life and even then I didn't
file them myself you know what I'm
saying it was his business accounting my
it was a conflict in interest in the
beginning my business accountant was his
business account right that umbrella
that umbrella that I walked into started
to be realizing that it was it was a
different problem my my my lawyer at the
time was hired through his lawyer right
you understand so all of us you know I
mean so a lot of those things that it
wasn't like nobody sitting down and
telling me you know what was going on of
course you know uh I did make the
decisions but you know I looked at it as
if
like this is my opportunity of a
lifetime and I know what I could do and
would do and did do with the opportunity
you know so that was more my focus more
than the business now looking back on
things if I was to do anything over it
was I would I would have I would have
had more knowledge and and took more
time in starting to learn the business
like I've had no choice to now you I
mean you were still pretty young during
the the whole gunit days right like
early 20 early 20s yeah early early 20s
uh I came in in in uh into gunit in 2002
2003 I'm 42 now so you can y'all can do
the math out there right now so out of
all the beef that you inherited would
you say like the IRS are the biggest
gangsters of them
all I will say they ain't to be
with you know and uh you know like I say
man my experien is uh just just going
through stuff like that i' you know how
your mom says this old saying uh a
hardhead make a soft ass you know
hardhead definitely does it's like a lot
of things that I I did do I I I knew I
shouldn't have been doing but instead I
I had a hard head and did it anyway
probably kind of like your crazy ass too
at that time you know what I'm saying
but yeah man it was just one of those
things where um had to learn the hard
way man for real for real and the IRS is
one of the best teachers you can have
yeah cuz there's nothing you can do
about it it's nothing you can do about
it and that was one of I experienced
some of the most heart heartful hurting
things that stuck to my life in regards
of dealing with uh bankruptcy and stuff
like that my first time after you know
going through all those things I end up
falling out with 50 during my first
bankruptcy and he pulled everything away
from me and I couldn't make no money
nowhere so I end up getting resorted
into uh all my stuff being auctioned off
so I woke up one morning and I'm in this
mansion and living my life and then I
got the IRS at my The Raid with the and
they're coming in and taking all my kids
stuff and and and all of those different
things and and and that in in that
process uh I had a tour manager at the
time had left a weapon in my home you
understand he left they waited eight
months they waited eight months bro to
indict me on that on the weapon that I
never knew that was there never touch no
fingerprints but the fact that the house
was in my name it sent me to federal
prison you know and Federal Federal
Prison man so what was your Char of my
life uh I did like 18 months over there
with dealing with that with that I went
to yazu yazu uh Federal Penitentiary I
started my first time going to the
penitentiary was the low uh and uh you
know that was a real experience for me
the low you mean low security low
security was my first I end up going
back you know but I I couldn't
understand uh you know I I mean I know
numerous people that it's caught
numerous gun charges but for some reason
the da at that time was
so you know adamant about uh sending me
to prison and stuff like that bro like
he was under the 50
umbrella I don't know I'm just kidding
but yeah man like at the that you know
they found a weapon in the house I I
didn't have no knowledge of it they
found a a bullet I used to have security
and stuff like that at my crib and stuff
they found one bullet that didn't even
match the gun that they found and
charged me with a fing in possession of
a fire uh uh amunition do do you think
the reason they went so hard on you is
cuz I feel like back then the da really
wanted to like make rappers an example
yeah uh of like when they up the da
where cuz that's uh it was in here it
was in Tennessee the D did the da the da
actually that prosecuted me in that
situation the first time was one of the
hard well he has a very very uh hard
reputation or in in throughout my city
for actually you know not playing and
really Prosecuting individuals so you
know I had no knowledge of who he was
until I started to deal with that case
in itself and uh you know honestly he he
kind of almost scared me
into to to to to playing out you know I
didn't know what he would do he you know
he was one of those Das and I don't know
if he still is a DA or what but he's one
of those da is like you know
uh he's going to get a conviction one
way or another if he's on your if he's
on your ass type of thing so it was
like I had a lot of individuals that I
had encountered with whether it was just
meeting not knowing what they got going
on speaking what up what up and he might
have seen me on a picture where they
watching these individuals and thinking
that I'm involved with these folks but
it's like man I'm a celebrity I meet a
lot of people but I don't know what the
hell they got going on and uh he took it
as if like yes you do so his whole thing
was about questioning me about you know
certain things dealing with certain
individuals that I couldn't provide no
no answers I didn't even choose to sit
down to talk to you why am I even going
to talk to you about something that I
don't know and once once he seen that I
I wouldn't cooperate in in in his method
of doing whatever he was trying to do he
told me straight up or told my attorney
you know what I'm saying that he was
going to he was going to send me to
prison and he did and I think I got
caught up as well in the middle of a lot
of the politics in my city because uh at
that time you
know uh my attorney is now the head of
the
da now so I think a lot of politics and
stuff came in in regard to I'm a big
fish in a small pond so that prosecution
of me was like I don't know maybe and
this is just me Wishful thaning I think
it was like I'll give you him if you
give me this type of thing like I don't
know man but hey I I got past that went
through that sentence got out it was
eight months for the gun no 18 months 18
months for the gun in federal prison
yeah was the difference between federal
prison and state prison like is there a
difference in I don't know I hope I
don't find out I'm actually fighting a
situation down the state you know what
I'm saying and and I'm totally innocent
in that situation like I say
[Music]
um I'm saying they coming already bro
like what's going on bro
like what are they
doing well we are in the hood yeah but
see ain't that crazy though for me to
say that
in but no honestly like um he's like you
guys wearing a wire yeah
but uh yeah man I got out from
completing that 18mon sentence man and
uh from there I uh I started I made a
decision at while I was in prison to to
actually go back to
gun you know and in my mind I felt like
cuz I I was away from gun when I went to
prison at that time like I say that
played a part of me going to prison
because 50 pulled out I didn't have
nothing you know what I'm saying so it
was one of those things that once I I
was in prison I'm and it's not like I I
I went to prison and was in no uh PC
protective custody or none of that I'm
actually walk in the yard with you know
you guys that got 15 20 years been there
20 30 years and all of this everything
that comes along with prison I I
experienced it I didn't experience it
from an end of uh uh you know being
celebrity yeah I'm I'm a celebrity and
individual saying yo can you sign this
for my kids you know what I'm saying
stuff like that so um my prison
experience was was was was real you know
I I I had a chance to meet a lot of
great dudes that was from all over the
world and that's one of the biggest
differences I would say within the state
and the federal is that you know you
meet all these different people from
everywhere and the state is kind of
mostly locally wherever you from and uh
they'll move you around wherever you
might be
in Mississippi for a
year California the next year you know
it just depends you know what I'm saying
exactly you know how they choose to move
you around and did that time got out and
uh in my mind I I always want I wanted
to you know finish what I started man
with gunit I didn't see myself not ever
not being a part of gunit I didn't want
things to be the way it is now you know
what I'm saying and even in prison my
whole thing was like bro whatever I need
to do to fix this bro to get back with
my brothers bro I'm going to do it and
uh shout out to coach PR and who kid man
they they they started really pushing
for the the gunit reunion and uh I was
out and they made it happen bro both of
them dudes man I love them dudes man
they they they made it happen they
pressed the issue enough with 50 I think
in regard to uh you know paying it
attention and he started to pay it
attention and I found myself back in New
York uh on the Summer Jam stage I forget
what year that was I it 2016 yep yep and
uh when the reunion happened did you
have any uh expectations like oh man
this is going to be like this is going
to explode just like it did in the early
2000s this is a fresh start did I did I
did and to this very day it still could
you know we are we are we are loved
grouped around around the world you know
what I'm saying and what we've done and
created with hip hop will last forever
so it my expectations was basically
picking up where it left off at because
even though you know things were you you
got a lot of different artists is that
was starting to you know blow we we had
we we are what we are now Legends we
we've already State stamped ourselves as
Legends in the game so it was like that
acceptance from the world of wanting to
see us together is even still there to
this very day for sure and um that was
like the beginning of getting everything
right in my mind it's like yeah so uh
the bond started to become a little bit
stronger and stuff like that you know
what I'm saying like cuz we've been
through this and been through that so we
started started working man we released
two projects I think the beauty of
Independence is one that we release once
once we re you know reunited and uh it
was another project I can't think that
was a mixtape yeah well he actually sold
those tapes so I can't really call them
mixtapes okay I I got to call them EPS
all right because they were two two EPS
that we drop and um you know everything
was rocking man and moving and wasn't it
that uh you guys got back together for
the summer JY put out the EPs and then
there was like an interview you said
that you didn't get any royalty checks
and then that just blew everything up it
blew everything up that's that's why I'm
in this that's that's why we're here
that's the real reason yeah it was never
over uh this false stuff that they put
out with the trends and all of this
crazy stuff that this that this dude
sits around and does but it was based on
the fact of me doing that interview and
speaking on the fact of saying I've
never received a royalty check but it
wasn't a lie it wasn't a lie I didn't I
didn't know I was doing the wrong thing
by by by expressing that you know what
I'm saying I I was actually giving it
and saying that based on the to to kind
of like let the world know like look at
all I got and I ain't never seen a
royalty Chas so I wasn't saying like 50
wasn't paying us or allowing us to get
money I was just being truthful like I
ain't never received a check well that
that was a lyric on get retro trying
yeah yeah so it's one of those things
though where you know at that time we
were just now getting back and I'll
never forget shamoney reaching out to me
and was like yo 50 is really tripping
over that man and I'm like damn bro what
I need to do like I didn't mean it that
way and
uh he was like yo bro I'm going try to
talk to him and you know I started to
reach out to him and
and uh was that was sha money still with
50 then y yep yep sha was still with 50
um you know sha was having his issues I
I I I think him and 50 wasn't on the
same page as they was they were having
their own personal issues which I
couldn't speak on because truthfully I
don't know exactly what their issues was
but that would they wouldn't on the same
page and uh
50 kind of left me like kind of pushed
me and shot to the to the side so we
kind of was rocking together in regards
to
anything um especially involved I was uh
on my second project coming out of my
second project at that time when all of
this started to happen and shamany came
running in and said yo like Buck cleared
10 million from gunit royalties exactly
and then
that sparked everything because sha
money tried to throw this at the time he
put the number out there like bucks made
over 10 million in his career and I'm
like I made some Millions but not that
you know what I'm saying so it was kind
of like he was just I I think overall
man and shout out to Shia money man he
was just trying to keep us together bro
you know and uh now do you know if if
banks and yo were were going were having
the same issues as you like not getting
any
royalties um if they were I don't know
their business but if they were they've
never spoken out or spoken on anything
you know what I'm saying I know I know I
don't really know the relationship that
they have I mean certainly 50 has
stated that every member of the gunit
cleared 10 million from that's not true
do you still have relationships with
banks in E
uh I have no problem when neither one of
them I haven't spoken to him in years
you know I don't know why uh I've
reached out the banks you know because I
I don't even know his situation with
gunit like that I know he's uh been been
releasing some some pretty dope projects
and stuff like that on his own and uh I
reached out but you know don't nobody
don't nobody reach back you dig I
reached out I've spoken to Yo maybe once
you know or at least reached out I know
he stays in in touch with my rightand
guy Charlie P and and they may speak
here and there but uh you know everybody
has a different kind of loyal iness you
know and his loyalty to 50 is um a
little deeper than than what mine was I
think in a sense they growed up together
all of them did you know except for me
I'm I'm all I'm almost like the outcast
of the group that that came in but also
one of the most talented in the group as
well I will stand on on that and I've
done a lot in regards of creating the
music and making the music for us as a
group and uh you know it shows you know
my absence I I I can say for a fact that
out of gunit that your verses are
my favorite and I appreciate that man
for real man yeah I hear that a lot
though and and and it's a good feeling
but I've always been a fan of of of of
of banks Yayo and 50 and even the game
you know what I'm saying to this very
day I ain't got no ill will with nobody
man I'm I'm out here trying to you know
keep giving the world good music feed my
family and move forward with with uh
with life in itself you know I'm not in
a place of going back and forth I'm I'm
I'm I've always been a real life
individual so I'm going stay that way
and if it's if it's real issues or it's
really that then at some point in time
we'll cross cross paths and see what it
is but for me to jump on podcast or
interviews and try to promote a beef or
having an issue with those dudes no
matter what they may say feel or think
about me it's no problem with me you dig
what I'm saying it's just like it
doesn't get to me no more man I used to
I used to wear my heart on my sleeve
dealing with this game man and uh uh
very emotional I'm a Pisces and I allow
my emotions to to to to to
overshadow a lot of things at times
where maybe I could have just you know
you're an artist shut the up but I
did you know what I'm saying but yeah
man I mean gunit would definitely not be
the same without Young Buck because
gunit was very New York and you added
that southern flare to it that just made
it like so much more hard it is man and
I learned a lot by being surrounded by
just
like East Coast artists they actually
got me on my game lyrically wise you
know what I'm saying because you got an
individual like Banks I've always felt
like Banks is one of the best rappers in
the game period punchline wise bar for
bar you better have your together
you know what I'm saying and to this
very day like Banks is dope uh Yayo Yayo
has his elements in what he brings he
has more energy than probably anybody in
this goddamn room you understand like yo
has a his own style he's not not
sounding like nobody or trying to be
nobody and I've always admired that
about yo it's like you know this is this
is what I bring to the table and stuff
like that and 50 showed me that even
though I'm from the south and stuff like
that I'm in an element of dealing with
artists that he he he he help mold my
sound where I can't even though I come
from the south I can't just put myself
as a southern artist because I'm almost
like a mixture of the East West and the
South and that's what was Young Buck you
know what I'm saying I got a southern
tone but at the same time I got a you
know by Coastal flow let me say that you
dig what I'm saying I'm every Coast kind
of plays a part into to what I do I
spent a lot of time on the west coast I
got a lot of family out there um you
know before gunit and doing gunit so
that plays a part in to me as an artist
as well so just by being a a rolling
stone and actually you know uh really
living in La really living in New York
you know really living in casville you
know and things like that it has made a
mixture of me pulling from everywhere
you know how much uh time do you spend
doing shows these days I mean man
they they paid all the bills for
2023 that's I mean shows is is like
that's what that's my favorite thing my
favorite thing in in music is being able
to get in front of the people that
actually appreciate and love what you
create so uh I man I I did a lot of
shows in 2023 and looked to do even more
in 2024 there it is I feel like 2024 is
like my like my job my rent Kobe year
you know what I'm saying it's like my
Kobe and like I don't I don't feel like
I'mma ever get old or something like
I'm forever young typee you don't feel
like that Steve H I can feel my age
creeping up on me well my knees and
hurt every now and then but you're in
shape dude yeah but I mean I I just I
just uh I don't want to get old let me
say that I don't want to get old so I
just stay like uh just stay as active as
I can I love music so I'm working all
day every day I got a session even when
I leave here uh with band play play
which is a big producer that started uh
out with me in the beginning and now
it's creating tracks for everybody in
the game right now and he's home for the
for the holiday so I'm G to rock with
him uh I'm pull up on Yellow Wolf real
quick he's got a brand new mansion he's
like yo bro you can't you're gonna
a brick when you see my new so you
know I got good motivation around me
jelly roll and everything he's doing and
and done for the city and still
continues to do his motivation to watch
these
individuals uh you know such such as
jelly R come from where I come from and
he's made his transition into the music
and and and watching him blowing up as
big as he is and actually keeping it 100
and and staying you know uh staying down
for the city of casville and just you
know that that's just motivation to
watch all these young artists to uh to
to go do their thing so we saw something
that um that said before there was Young
Buck there was this thing called The
Curse of Nashville and you were the
artist that really broke the curse Yeah
Yeah by far it was a bad curse of
Nashville like it was one of those
situations where I actually had to get
up out of Nashville to actually go get
some ground and get some movement around
me but it also made me really realiz
that I had to take the end and just move
it to the side and put the C there to
name the city Cashville because what I
found to realize was I might be in a
room full of artists that was one from
La one from New York one's from Atlanta
and just because of where they're from
they get the first look I'm better than
all these guys but just because they
represent a bigger city or or a bigger
thing so I started to say
it seemed like every time I say out from
Nashville it was like oh man this
going to be some country or you
know they they kind of looked at it as
if it
was you know not just as Hood Street and
everything else as in any any other
ghetto is no ghetto bigger than my your
ghetto ain't no harder than mine so it
was like those were the aura and eras of
artists that I was dealing with at those
times so then I I I I started saying you
know what damn man my city is is just
like La my city is just like these
projects and queens and all of these
things so how can I uh respect the
heritage of Nashville which is country
music and also let them see that there's
a different side to Nashville as well
and that's when I came up with Cashville
so it turned from me saying I'm from
Nashville to Cashville and then that was
more intriguing
especially in the hip hop world to hear
that and a lot of people thought
Cashville was an actual place
they didn't know it was Nashville so I'm
saying I'm from casville
like bro I got to go there you know what
I'm saying they get money out there you
what I'm saying not knowing that it's
actually Nashville bro you know what I'm
saying I yeah D they're they're printing
money in Nashville man yeah bro this is
actually you know a lot of artists get
get a lot of Fame and a lot of money and
then they move from home I've watched a
lot of artists uh booy says uh I think
on an interview I had seen him he was
like you know uh you get a lot of
artists get you know this money and fame
and they never leave their home and then
that's when tragedy or things like that
starts to happen and a lot of times it
does but in my city I end up coming from
a city that's on the rise so for me to
leave my city I feel like no I have to
dive in and be a part of the rise you
know what I'm saying cuz it's so much
opportunity out here I think we're the
number two growing the city in the world
type thing you know you look up and it's
so many people here like like it's crazy
like everybody's running to Nashville to
live and Stu Miami number one Nashville
number two Miami huh Florida somewhere
in Florida I thought Austin was number I
think Austin yeah it's crazy bro like
here man everywhere you look if we walk
outside now and and I don't know if
y'all notice but if you look up in the
air and turn into 360 you'll see cranes
in every motion that you go so the
skyline that that we look at here in
Nashville I remember it was this big now
it's becoming this big on the way to
becoming this big so I just want to I
want to actually you know uh I've
learned business a lot more than then so
I'm I'm in the process of trying to uh
opened up a few different businesses and
things like that around here just to uh
not only honor my career and what I've
done for my city but to uh let you know
Out of Towners and stuff like that get
an experience of buck you dig so my
thing is trying to open up a I want to
do a bar pretty dope bar something like
that I mean we got a lot of country
music artist that has bars and stuff
downtown on Broadway but there's no
there's no
uh let me say this there's
no bar pretty much in Broadway well they
do have a few of them I don't want to
take away from the city but where
there's like uh either either it's
country music or or it's or it's hip hop
I want to kind of create a spot where
it's a little like a mesh of everything
you know what I'm saying we going to
play some rock we going to play some pop
we going to play some rap we going some
you know and that's what I feel like our
city is is in need of in the Broadway
area because if you go down there you
see Jason
Alin uh shout out to him shout out to my
guy Kid Rock me and Kid Rock hang out
he's a good dude I've been that's a wild
boy y'all shout out to Kid Rock bro he's
a he showed a lot of love to me and
stuff like that and he's got a a dope
bar and stuff like that downtown as well
but I just like like I say I love seeing
everybody together so I want to just
kind of have a spot where it's just a
mesh of everything and everybody has a
has an experience of casville as a whole
versus then separating it where oh just
because it's country music you got to
listen to here or they only do country
music I just want to do everything we
play everything we all come together and
just party because this is a
City that don't sleep pretty
much yeah yeah and uh with
with with touring like like what what
what's your hub for for for people to
get in on all your oh man uh of
course you can follow me on all the the
social media networks my my Instagram
page is buck shots with a z um my
Twitter is Young Buck uh my Facebook is
Young Buck and stuff like that but uh
yeah you and you and me have followed
each other on Twitter for like forever
yeah now I got to follow you on the
Instagram yeah me too
manse but uh yeah man and then and uh my
booking info and booking information is
is in the bio of all my social networks
so it's not really hard to get in me you
know what I'm saying if you need me to
pull up and come hug the babies or or or
perform just let me know you know what I
mean I ain't going to charge it too much
you know I'll come to the cookouts and
the the weddings you know like I say I I
I just I just love the fact of being
able to touch people through music
because that's where I come from but one
of my biggest Focus this year is to to
do as many films as possible I really
want to get off into the acting world I
think that it's it's it's like going to
be
like a new a new career or a new wave in
a sense for me music I'm never stop
doing music uh a lot of my fans is
excited just because I'm at this point
where I'm actually about to start
dropping music again and uh I got a lot
a lot of music so I'm I'm looking for
2024 to be a very musical year for young
bu you dig good man well hell yeah dude
hey man listen bro it's great to see
cheers bro liquid death cheers
bro that's right man well dude everybody
get on that IG get get on that Twitter
get on get on that booking and and get
ready for that bar hey man listen man
I'm working hard on it man also I want
to let uh I've I'm I'm big on food so I
do for a minute I really was doing a lot
of cooking throughout the Instagram and
showing people that you know I can turn
into Chef BR buck and
uh just showing off my little my little
but I love to cook so I'm also looking
to uh open up a restaurant
and uh do something different with that
kind food yeah yeah just oh what kind of
food of course southern food but I want
to do some different you know just
different things like uh you know I
might wake up and just come up with some
like that you know um but just kind
of like a mixture of all kind of foods
yeah you know southern food I ain't
going to say the bases but you know I
want to have Habachi Southern like very
seldom do you go to a restaurant where
you can
actually get anything you know what I'm
saying like you can go get
some pork chops and turn greens and a
and a tomahawk or a fet meon or you go
over here and get a Habachi so and I
honestly I want to call it with your
hungry
ass you know what I'm saying so it's
just like if you're hungry we got
whatever you want you know what I'm
saying sushi but it's just like a
restaurant where you go in you know how
you're usually going to a steak
restaurant you're going to a you know
seafood restaurant just a spot where it
has everything in regards to food and
just the vibe because I feel like life
is kind of like based on Vibes as well
you know just to have a great atmosphere
and just a good place for people to
actually not only enjoy the food but
enjoy the music because Everywhere I Go
music got to go so it's just one of
those things where business wise when
I'm thinking of business I'm I'm almost
kind of adding the music in into
whatever I choose to yeah I think the
restaurant in the bar could probably be
the same thing it' be the same thing you
dig or at least we can have some of the
same crazy ass foods and I'll be
coming up with at least in the bar you
know who knows man what the future holds
but I do know 2024 is my uh my cob year
you know so get so get used to me again
you word hell yeah man thank you bu I
appreciate you bro nice to meet you
there you have it folks this was the
first podcast of the new year and I want
to wish everybody all of the Good
Fortune and happiness in this new year
and I want you to wish that to Young
Buck if you can give him some love my
beautiful street team that'll mean a lot
um and uh we we should try to send this
episode maybe even in advance to some
hipop music
Outlets trying to get this episode some
extra love because man it was killer
buck was just a humbl just great dude
and uh you know not a lot of people go
through tough times like that and come
out as a you
know like that I mean dude I loved it I
love you too thank you for sticking
around to the very end and best wishes
and lots of love in the new
year yeah
dude